what the heck is going on with house
prices right now I'm going to be
explaining that in this video I've been
researching the heck out of the economy
of house prices and ultimately how to
make money right in property I've been
investing now in property for 14 15
years I've got millions of pounds in
property and the media are talking about
how there's a crash and how house prices
are going to crash like crazy and now is
the time to sell do not buy and I
thought I had a moral responsibility to
my subscribers to talk about what the
heck is going on so firstly I did do a
prediction video a few months back just
the back end of last year and I did say
that I thought house prices were going
to go down in 2023 around about 10 since
saying that house prices have dropped
every month consecutively house prices
have dropped consecutively five months
in a row
interest rates are higher than they've
been for years literally it was only a
matter of months ago when base rates was
0.1 percent
now it's four percent that is how many
times 40 times it's it's gone up 40 40
times so it's quite a scary time right
now if you're a property investor
because the houses are dropping and
rates are rising and tenants rights are
getting stronger so if you buy a house
and you rent it out you're probably not
going to be making that much money
because interest rates are so freaking
high right now and again I predicted
this would happen last year I said house
um interest rates would go up by luckily
myself and many of my uh followers fix
their rates so my interest rates are
fixed until 2027 at three percent so
that's kind of okay for me but what
about getting into the market now is now
a good time to buy well I'm gonna hit
you with a crazy prediction that's going
to shock you and that is I believe
but throughout the year of 2023 house
prices are going to go up that's what I
think it's not what the media is saying
the media is saying right I think house
prices are going to go up now I'm going
to put a caveat to that I'm not talking
about all house prices
I'm talking about my house prices what
do I mean by that listen folks when
you're a sophisticated property investor
don't worry about what's going to happen
to the economy you should be thinking
about what's going to be happening to
your economy don't think about what's
going to happen to the market you need
to think about what's going to happen in
your Market this is the biggest piece of
advice I can give property investors
right now in 2023. everyone's wondering
what's going to happen what's going to
happen to the economy you create your
own economy so my houses are going to go
up by 25 how because I only buy houses
that I know I can push the value up by
25 most people what they do is they buy
a house and then they just wait and see
what happens that is not a smart way to
invest in property if you buy a house
and think let's see what happens now
don't get me wrong if you do that you
will probably end up rich assuming you
can afford the deposits because on
average house prices historically double
in value every 10 years here's what most
people do they see house prices going up
and they think oh house prices are going
up I'm gonna get I'm gonna get ready to
buy and they meet with their mortgage
advisor and and they start saving and
then what happens is house prices take a
little dip and they go whoa whoa whoa
okay house prices are dipping
um let me just wait to see what happens
and then house processes go down and
they're thinking oh thank God I didn't
buy and then oh my gosh they go up again
oh they're going up okay um let's start
saving and they start I've never been
something down and then and then that
keeps happening and then they die and
they don't ever buy anything that is the
worst thing to do and the reason they do
this is because they're they're
constantly waiting they're thinking
what's going to happen two house prices
in the next 6 months in the next 12
months I do believe that house prices
are going to drop generally speaking
across the board throughout 2023. not
massively I think they're going to go
down by maybe about 10 and the reason
that's happening and here's the
interesting thing
the reason that they're dropping is
because of interest rates when I said
base rate went from 0.1 to 4 let me
explain what base rate is base rate is
how much the banks charge to loan money
to the other Banks so when you go to a
standard like you know you might go to a
High Street bank and get a mortgage out
how is that mortgage company giving you
the money well they're giving it you
because they borrowed it from another
bank maybe they borrowed it from the
bank of England so they borrowed 100
Grand from the bank of England
previously they were paying the bank of
England 0.1 so they could afford to give
you interest of maybe two percent three
percent now because base rate is four
percent when the banks loan you money
they need to still make profit that's
why buy select mortgages you're
typically talking around six percent at
the moment because they've got to make
profit but six percent if you were
previously paying two or three percent
has gone up more than double well what
does that mean that means if your
interest rates previously when you
bought a buy to that house were 400 quid
a month and your rent was 800 a month
and you're making profit now you're
making nothing so now it's much harder
to make profit from buying a per house
to rent out buy to let is less
profitable than it was because interest
rates have increased and as a result of
that people can't afford to buy houses
even to live in if you want to buy a
house and you want to live in the house
previously you might have thought oh how
much are the rates going to be yeah I
can afford to buy that house I can
afford to pay the mortgage now because
interest rates are so high most people
are going to think forget that I'm not
buying a house and paying I can't afford
to pay the interest it's cheaper to rent
so less people are able to afford to buy
houses because of the interest and
because less people are able to afford
houses because of the mortgage rates
then houses aren't selling as quickly
house prices are coming down if you're a
cash buyer you're laughing but if you're
getting a more if you're buying with a
mortgage is really hard so what's the
solution solution simple number one buy
houses for cash and buy them cheap okay
now you might think I don't have any
cash you know I've I've got any money
that's okay because if you get a really
good banging deal and you can buy it
cheap and you know that you can push the
value up I'll give you an example
um if you're buying a house we're buying
house at the moment in London and we're
buying it for just under a million
pounds but we know that within for half
a million pounds if we spend half a
million on it we can turn it to four
flats
so in total you might say well it's one
and a half million pounds in in total
but we also know that once we've
converted it into four flats we've
increased the end value because the
flats in London in that part of London
are selling for no less than half a
million so now we've bought it for a
million we've spent half a million on it
so in total 1.5 but we've pushed the
value up we've forced the value up by
how much 25 percent
so that's what you need to be doing and
you can use on a much smaller scale
you've probably seen me do this I helped
craps do this crept and coming and crept
went to Liverpool bought a house for 43
Grand
very very cheap house then he spent 30
grams doing what pushing the value up so
in total he spent about 75 grams but
then the new value was 100 so how much
profit did he make 25 Grand but more
importantly what was the profit
percentage 25 so right now in 2023 if
you wanted to buy properties you you'd
be thinking well hang on as long as I
can buy at the right price and as long
as the property's got a problem and I
can push the value up if I can force the
value up then I don't have to worry
about what's going to happen to house
prices because I know what's going to
happen to my house prices they're going
to go up by 25 or more and once you've
pushed the value up by 25 what are you
gonna do
refinance and pull back out your deposit
pull back out your investment and that's
why I say even if you've not got cash it
doesn't matter because you can you can
Bridge the money you can borrow the
money on a bridge this is called buy
refurbish refinance rent we still have a
problem though
the problem is still well even if we do
that if interest rates are so high and
we're not making much cash flow then we
have a problem also if tenants are
struggling or not paying their rent and
they're talking about scrapping and
abolishing section 21 then how are we
going to rent out the property and still
make enough profit and the solution to
that is very very simple and this is
something that I've been doing now
successfully for many years and that is
short stay let's if you rent your
property out instead of renting out on
an AST contract for a monthly rent to a
family if you rent it out on short stay
let's advertise it to contractors
relocators tourists business
professionals then firstly you've got
way more rent because if you were
previously renting a house out for say a
thousand pounds a month but now you're
renting out on a nightly basis for a
hundred pound a night that's three
thousand pounds a month so you've
tripled the rent
sure you're gonna have cleaners and some
costs associated with it but still
you're going to be making double the
profit which means that even though
you've got the problem with interest
rates being high you're still making
considerably more money
also if you do short stay laps it's tax
effective it means that you can you're
able to claim back the mortgage payments
as tax deductible which is amazingly
important especially when interest rates
are high so I think the absolute best
strategy of 2023 is to buy houses and
push the value up so you're not hoping
all what's going to happen and rent them
out on Short Stay less of course this
takes due diligence you need to know
where you're buying you need to check
the um the market and certainly property
investing is not easy property investing
is something that's going to take skill
training resources a power team but if
you really spend just a few days or a
few weeks really immersing yourself on
learning how to invest in property
properly well everybody else is waiting
for the crash while everybody else is
scared you should be greedy and that's
what Warren Buffett says distinguishes
successful investor it's when people are
greedy you should be scared
scared you should be greedy stuff I hope
this has helped guys my name is Samuel
if you enjoyed the video hit like drop a
comment and I'll be sure to make another
video real soon explaining in more
detail how you can kill it in 2023